Hey guys you know what I love
Yes, I'm pretty sure all of us would love a personal elevator and a giant mansion that has a cool Sailor Moon phone
Oh but before I go on you may have noticed I'm in a hotel room
And that is because I am currently
Overseas starring in a movie called go back to China.
YaAaaAaay *fireworks* *confetti*
I'm very excited for all the friends. I'm making
Blub Blub Blub Blub Blub~~~~
But even though I'm in China. I didn't want to talk today about a
universally needed trait
Empathy you know we can't control
What happens to us, but what we can control is our reaction to those events and you know I'm not
I'm not the best of us all of it
Okay, like I have a lot of anger issues about stuff that may or may not be justified
Why does every fruit plate have honey - honeydew with the poor man strawberry!?
Honeydews have 90 percent water!
I want some nutritious Blueberries!
Kiwi, Pineapple, Dragonfruit, and there's rasberries!
NO ONE LIKES THIS HONEYDEW!!
Anna... that's Cantolope...
Oh wow...
wow I feel so foolish
Guess I don't like cantaloupe
But I have learned
That when you approach a situation with gentleness instead of going with your first instinctive reaction of being like harsh and defensive and angry you
Learn so much more about yourself and about others so about like a year ago now
I had this lady sort of explode at me out of nowhere
She was texting on her phone, and she had bumped into me, and I was like. "Oh sorry!", and she just went off
And it was so uncalled for like her reaction did not fit this situation at all, and I was just like hey
Are you okay is something going on here? I I don't know what came over me. I'm really sorry dad
I'm sorry yeah, my sister actually died
It turned out that her father had recently died by suicide and for those of you who don't know my sister
Died that way as well, and we had this very long conversation just sort of about mortality
And what it what it means to like lose an immediate family member this way and after the whole incident
I was just like you know what wow I never would have shared this connection with a
stranger if I had just given
Into that first instinct of being really defensive and angry I'd just been like well screw you too lady so the next time you're in
a circumstance that ignites your anger jealousy insecurity or any other negative emotion try to respond in a more gentle more kind way instead I
Truly believe in the idea that every other human being is you and I know it's hard to like actually live that
But it's true
I mean we all have our unique and individual experiences
but ultimately
feelings are universal so be kind to yourself be kind to others spread that stuff around because
One day you're gonna be in the position where you really need someone to pick up the slack and be kind to you
And it's gonna make all the difference so thank you so much Pantene for sponsoring today's video and promoting such a mindful
Message of like compassion and empathy, that's just awesome as you guys know. I have a beautiful mane of hair
And I feel really lucky and honored that I get to be sponsored by a company
That's so conscious of like the social messages that they're putting out into the world
You know the Internet can be a dark scary place like a very sad from it a lot of the time and so it's really
Nice when you get to talk about something positive and uplifting and kind of spread that around be sure to check out, Priyanka, Chopra
So gentle video which is in the description bar below, I'm Anna, Akana
Stay awesome Gotham